[Musik]
zwischen der bayerischen gemeinde
bachhagel und im baden-württembergischen
dischingen endet dieser radweg direkt an
der grenze auf der bayerischen seite
seit herbst 2017 schafft es baden
württemberg nicht die zwei restlichen
kilometer fertig zu bauen radfahrer
kommen hier nicht weiter sie müssen
wenden und auf die viel befahrene
landesstraße ausweichen die menschen auf
der ostalb sind stinksauer
meiner meinung nach ist das hier das
ganze harakiri wir haben hier die
radfahrer an einer viel befahrenen
landesstraße mit schwerlastverkehr auf
die straße wechseln müssen absoluter
schwachsinn ich bin sehr viel fahrrad
unterwegs und wenn ich mit meinen enkeln
zum beispiel nachgingen fahren möchte
zum eis essen kann ich mit ihnen hier
nicht auf diese straße fahren das letzte
was das gibt wie man so was machen kann
das ist doch aber im september 2017 ist
die neue ortsumfahrung ums bayerische
bachhagel herum fertig gleichzeitig
bauen die bayern parallel zur straße ein
radweg aber an der landesgrenze ist für
radler plötzlich schluss denn in baden
württemberg passiert erstmal gar nichts
obwohl der länderübergreifend radweg im
maßnahmenplan des landes steht um die
absurde situation zu verenden bietet der
bürgermeister der gemeinde dischingen
seinem bundesland hilfe an
mit der planung und dem bau würde die
kommunen vorleistung gehen wenn das land
die kosten übernimmt aber baden
württemberg will nicht alles zahlen im
rathaus ist man verärgert in ordnung war
das land baden württemberg macht sie
bedient sich der gemeinden wobei mir
gerne bereits in das land zu
unterstützen aber es kann nicht sein
dass die gemeinde dann eigene
finanzielle mittel einsetzen muss vor
aufgaben die das land zu übernehmen hat
bisher war der radweg auf der fahne und
ostalb dem land nicht wichtig genug aber
die proteste und der unmut vor ort
scheinen im stuttgarter
verkehrsministerium plötzlich wirkung zu
zeigen
der wille diesen radweg zu bauen ist da
das geld wird zur verfügung gestellt und
wir werden alles tun dass es so schnell
wirklich kommt den versprechungen aus
der landeshauptstadt trauen sie in
dischingen noch nicht über den weg
also wenn dieses jetzt zahlen würden
hoffe dass das so ist und das ist nicht
nur lippenbekenntnisse sind auch unsere
bayerischen grenze unserer nachbarn ja
das sind wir schon echt große lacher
eine lachnummer
ja es ist unerträglich dass schnitt
normal also für uns ist es pro spiel
wenn die gemeinde dem neuen angebot
zustimmt kann es frühestens 2020 mit dem
bau losgehen
vielleicht ist der radweg ins nichts ja
wenigstens ein gutes ostereier versteckt
denn hier kommt so schnell niemand
vorbei um zu suchen